it almost seems to be an unwritten
hollywood rule that for every amazing
well-crafted piece of cinema released in
any given year there must be at least
one completely misguided poorly executed
lazily written slog of a film 2019 is no
exception and these are the worst movies
of the bunch
keanu reeves is as in demand as ever and
has even cemented his action star
bonafides relatively late in his career
thanks to the john wick series over the
years he's only appeared in a handful of
sci-fi features so we were psyched to
see his return to the world of trippy
sci-fi weirdness with replicas then the
reviews started to come in according to
critics the film was a complete mess
plagued by a clumsy script written in
service of an absurd storyline even
worse for an action star of reeves
caliber it also featured unexciting
action sequences and plot holes you
could drive a semi through the guardians
charles burmesco offered up a roger
ebert-esque review that took everyone
but reeves to task if only anyone else
involved could muster a fraction of the
consummate professionalism that reeves
brings to his dead serious intonation of
the word algorithm this doa science
project might have had a pulse all we
can say to that review is
2017 split was rightfully hailed as a
return to form for director m night
shyamalan especially for its last minute
reveal just before the credits rolled
audiences realized that split was a
stealth sequel to shyamalan's amazing
2000 film unbreakable shyamalan brought
it all together for the third film in
the sudden trilogy glass which promised
us a superpowered throwdown for the ages
typical of many of shyamalan's movies a
vocal minority of critics found it to be
a misunderstood masterpiece everyone
else however simply found it to be
poorly written plottingly paced and
boring critic mahmoud mahdi of film
jumed summed up the film with one harsh
sentence in his review a wagon carrying
dramatic garbage advancing on rails at a
constant pace to reach a destination
where nobody ever wanted to go
serenity starring matthew mcconaughey as
fishing boat captain in anne hathaway as
an ex-wife who shows up seeking
protection from her new abusive husband
is a seedy murder mystery with a twist
the problem unfortunately is that the
mystery isn't so tough to parse out and
the twist is absolutely ridiculous in
case you think we're being hyperbolic
consider the word to the great critic
rex reed who has seen a bad movie or two
in his distinguished career writing for
the observer around the movie's release
in january
reed argued serenity already qualifies
as the worst film of 2019. both
moronically written and directed with
shocking amateurish ineptitude by steven
knight it's a pointless bomb say what
you will about the movie but that sure
doesn't sound alright alright alright
gina rodriguez is probably most familiar
to audiences by way of her starring role
on the cw's romantic comedy series jane
the virgin so it's a little unclear why
miss balo would attempt to make her over
as an action star a remake of the 2011
spanish film of the same name miss bala
stars rodriguez as a makeup artist who
gets caught up in an extremely
convoluted cross-border drug trafficking
plot while attempting to help a friend
win a beauty contest while the film
itself was roundly panned critics made
sure to give rodriguez some credits bill
gabiri riding at the rolling stone
managed to ding the film and praise
rodriguez in the same review this
hollywood-eyes remake is mostly generic
and uninspired but it also proves that
rodriguez has the makings of a true
movie star it'll be exciting to see what
she does next so long as it's not a
sequel to this
another year another entry in the
seemingly unkillable medea series every
new installment brings two different
sets of lines around the block fans who
can't wait to catch the latest outing
and critics who can't wait to take their
shots tyler perry's a medea family
funeral was certainly no different
garnering 72 million dollars at the
domestic box office while reliably
bringing out maximum snark in virtually
every reviewer tasked with sitting
through it frank scheck of the hollywood
reporter definitely didn't hold any
punches considering how well the
characters served him perry certainly
doesn't return the favor in this
graceless installment combining raucous
comedy and turgid melodrama to
undigestable effects this film like
almost all of his others has a tossed
off quality giving the impression it was
written and shot over a long weekend
john travolta has accomplished many
things in his career he helped to cement
the popularity of disco assisted quentin
tarantino in reinventing the crime film
and traded faces with nicholas cage to
name just a few but 2019 saw him notch
perhaps his most dubious achievements
fielding a picture which scored a big
fat goose egg on rotten tomatoes for the
third time in two years his misbegotten
biopic gotti and woefully inept speed
boat racing thriller speed kills were
considered by many to be the worst films
of 2018. trading paint the story of
father and son race car drivers pitted
against each other by an unscrupulous
rival is shaping up to be a strong
contender for this year's title the 11
critics who bothered to review it
trashed it mercilessly none more so than
johnny oleksinski of the new york post
the races of training paint are as
exciting as a ford tourist trying to
parallel park the silver lining here a
losing streak this egregious usually
means there's nowhere to go but up
director guillarmo del toro's hellboy
adaptation from 2004 and its 2008 sequel
the golden army were fine adaptations of
the famous comic book character and the
two movies have plenty of fans to this
day that's largely thanks to the
director's unabashed love for the
material as well as a lead performance
from ron perlman in a role he was born
to play
a third del toro directed installment
was rumored for years but fell apart due
to the producers desire to go the reboot
route much to the disappointment of
pearlman and many fans but with stranger
things david harbour in the lead the
dissents neil martial on the director's
chair and a hard r rating the 2019
edition of hellboy looked promising that
is right up until it landed in theaters
with a resounding thud while there was
plenty of praise for harper's take on
the character critics found it to be a
performance in service of a terrible
film spencer period coming soon let it
fly in a brutal review the new hellboy
wouldn't be so bad if it wasn't so
boring and ugly to look at moments that
happened just for the sake of moving the
plot could be forgiven but its garish
visuals hinder it and its plotting plot
doesn't come together in any satisfying
way
at first blush a genderflip take on the
1988 comedy classic dirty rotten
scoundrels which featured michael kane
and steve martin as dueling con men
vying over the territory of a seaside
resort seemed like a premise with a lot
of potential the hustle also had a lot
going for it anne hathaway and rebel
wilson in the lead roles along with veep
veteran chris addison in the director's
chair but something must have gone wrong
between the conception and execution
because the hustle debuted to some of
the harshest critical thrashings of the
year thus far one time roger ebert
cohort richard roper channeled his old
friend in his blistering review for the
chicago sun times so predictable just
like everything in this movie if you
don't see the long con coming in this
story either you're not paying attention
or
no that's the only possible explanation
your mind wandered to thoughts of better
movies playing elsewhere perhaps right
next door to this debacle meanwhile the
detroit news adam graham perhaps nailed
the film the hardest who's conning who
here in the hustle everyone's a sucker
most of all the audience
the intruder is a bit of an anomaly a
film featuring a widely praised
performance from a veteran actor that
was nevertheless mercilessly dragged by
critics the performance in question
comes from square jaw generally nice
dennis quaid as charlie peck a seemingly
nice older dude who sells his family
home to a young couple only to creepily
insinuate himself into their lives
quaids against type wildly over the top
performance might have been remembered
as one of the ages by thriller
aficionados if only it had been in the
service of a better film film frenzy's
matt brunson took particular issue with
how poorly the film set up its
protagonist if the protagonists in this
film were any more dense they would only
exist as a thick fog nearly every
negative review similarly lamented the
film's utter predictability and
ham-fisted jump scares while admitting
that seeing quaid play a complete psycho
was pretty fun the critical movie
critic's frank ochieng said
unimaginative and clumsy this generic
grown-at-home sideshow's only genuine
appeal is watching veteran screen star
quade overly ham hammered up as the
intruding nutty nemesis hell bent on
reclaiming his territory
poms build itself is an uplifting comedy
about a group of women who start up a
cheerleading squad in their retirement
home and with a premise like that
casting is everything fortunately screen
legends diane keaton pam greer and ria
pearlman were all on board and the
reviews certainly had no problems with
the cast instead the critic's issues
were with virtually everything else
about the film it probably didn't help
that palms was a debut feature for both
director zara hayes and screenwriter
shane atkinson critics took the movie to
task for everything from wasting his
brilliant cast to disrespecting the age
group it was meant to uplift ella taylor
at npr pointed out a particularly grim
plot point in her review of the film by
hitching martha's imminent death to the
innocuous frivolity of a comic
cheerleading plot haze and screenwriter
shane atkinson take on responsibilities
they can't follow through on without
getting into a tonal and thematic tangle
as a fable of end-of-life empowerment
the movie has all the existential heft
of an extended l'oreal commercial rex
reed of the observer succinctly pointed
out the biggest problem in the film and
it's not any of the talented cast it's
the witless script by shane atkinson and
the petrified direction by zara hayes
that lands everyone in traction
the films of the conjuring universe have
certainly made their share of box office
bank but critically they've been a bit
of a mixed bag in just the last couple
years reviewers have swung from hots in
the case of 2019's annabelle comes home
to ice cold for 2018's the nun
unfortunately the response to the curse
of la jorona based on a creepy bit of
mexican folklore that seemed right for
cinematic exploration came down firmly
on the cold side of that equation
focusing on a social worker who incurs
the wrath of a supernatural entity that
preys on children la yorona turned
critics off with its extreme reliance on
formulaic scares making things worse
some felt it failed to do justice to the
true creepiness of the legend on which
it's based according to alternate
endings tim brayton it can only barely
get jump scares right every single one
of them for the film's first hour is set
up staged and timed exactly the same way
so that they start to feel less like
visceral sucker punches and more like a
baffling and unfunny running gag but
national post chris knight put the final
nail in lyurona's coffin some horror
films like last year's hereditary are
flat out horrifying others such as the
recent halloween or pet cemetery reboots
are legitimately frightening the curse
of lyorona is neither of these the best
you could say is it's startling
dark phoenix was supposed to be a lot of
things an epic send off to the heroes of
the fox produced x-men series a proper
film adaptation to one of the greatest
marvel story lines of all time and
ideally a hit movie but because of an
extensive reworking of its third act and
the inexperience of first-time director
simon kinberg it ended up being exactly
none of those things matthew lacona of
the san diego reader seemed nearly
disappointed when he wrote his review it
didn't have to end this way in such
thoroughly standard smash-em-up fashion
with minor heroes dutifully duking it
out with faceless hordes for punchy
power bolts minute after punchy power
bolt minute until the mayhem quotient
has been met and the principles can
finally square off for their climactic
light show
more reviews like michael calaris of the
niagara gazette seem to echo the
melancholy much of the cast actually
looks exhausted some of them seem as if
a paul of enwy has settled over their
persona dark phoenix is a dull money
grab and nothing more
fielding a fourth installment in the men
in black series seven years after the
previous installment without franchise
stars will smith and tommy lee jones was
always a bit of a risky proposition
still men in black international had two
charismatic leads in chris hemsworth and
tessa thompson who had already proven
their amazing screen chemistry with thor
ragnarok
all right for sonnyvalden i need to get
back to husband
many apologies you may just do
unfortunately it takes more than just a
couple of funny and talented actors to
make a good movie even with the
participation of iron man scribes art
markham and matt holloway and friday
director f gary gray men in black
international fell woefully short of
past installments of the franchise joe
morgenstern of the wall street journal
barely seemed willing to review the film
at all no need to huff and puff about
the idiocy of men in black international
it is what it is an industrial product
recycled from the remnants of an
exhausted franchise and aimed at a young
audience that may not know or care what
a joy the original was while many
reviewers had praise for hemsworth and
thompson's comedic stylings the movie as
a whole was roundly trashed oliver jones
at the observer spared some brief praise
for kumel nanjiani's alien character
pawnee before blasting away at the film
certainly pawnee is mildly cute and
wielding a tiny sword that looks like it
might struggle to mince garlic mostly
harmless those are also the nicest
things you can say about the movie he is
in a largely toothless and wit free
reboot that empties the last of the
originality and vivacity that has been
steadily leaking out of the franchise
with each subsequent installment
on paper it sounded shaft-tastic richard
roundtree reprising his role as john
shaft from the iconic 1971 original
samuel l jackson returning as his son
john shaft jr from the well received
2000 sequel and jesse usher as jj shaft
the latest in the line of famous
badasses unfortunately it didn't live up
to any of its potential and critics
generally agreed that shaft 2019 was a
throwback in all the wrong ways peter
travers of rolling stone called the film
shamelessly regressive in his review
rough justice is back to stay women are
out of the picture except for sex
dinosaurs again walk the earth with
misogynistic and homophobic impunity
these are the laughs folks
don't be surprised if they stick in your
throats roger ebert.com's odie henderson
was arguably even harsher on the film
saying this movie is ruin your childhood
bad right down to the hideous auto-tuned
end credits song they chose to use
instead of the original theme from shaft
but jason bailey of flavor wire summed
it up the best writing if you know one
thing about john shaft's history and
legacy the film is downright depressing
french director luke basan has made a
career out of making ultra stylized
flicks featuring extremely formidable
women from 1990s nikita to 1997's the
fifth element to 2014's lucy for his
latest exploration of this theme he
recruited russian supermodel sasha luss
for the title role in anna the story of
an everyday woman who happens to look
like a russian supermodel and somehow
becomes a cold-blooded killer for the
kgb if it all sounds a little familiar
critics agreed many found the film so
highly reminiscent of besson's previous
work that it bordered on self parody
this may have been fine if the picture
were serviceably made but most observers
found bason to be stuck firmly in
neutral with anna a sparsely plotted
film with a distinct lack of imagination
the guardian's benjamin lee said that
what ultimately sings the film is its
overwhelming blandness from the lack of
creativity employed in anna's many kills
to bassan's inability to choreograph a
pulse racing action scene and the
scripts be labored attempts to jump back
and forward in time to wrongfooters only
highlight how little it brings to the
table meanwhile peter sabzinski of
rogereber.com critiqued the film for not
living up to bassan's previous works
even long-standing fans of his will find
it hard to muster much enthusiasm for
the startlingly lazy bit of by the
numbers hack work in short most critics
responses were best summed up in one
line i
am very disappointed
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you